[Music]
[Music]
very often people think it's gonna be
funny and then they realize it's not
really
we really do music it's not impossible
to make music with vegetables my name is
Susanna Katya and then I'm a member of
the vegetable orchestra the orchestra
exists since 18 years now if first
instrument was the tomato because you
can do sound with tomatoes but it will
be messy for sure
we go shopping on the market first we
choose all the vegetables there we have
three kinds of instruments one is the
ready mate you can just buy it at the
market and play it it's like the pepper
it's cold it's ready already and then
there are the simple instruments like
with one cut or some cuts to get it like
that then with the more complex
instruments we have some that work like
normal instruments you know the pumpkin
is the bass drum and the sound of the
pumpkin is really important after
shopping we go to the venue and start to
build instruments all in all it takes
two to three hours to build all the
instruments for everybody and then we
start with the soundcheck and since we
have new instruments each time we have
to have a very long story
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a lot of different musical
influences in the orchestra since we're
really many people everybody's
interested in different things we make
soup during the building process of the
vegetable instruments with the remaining
vegetables when we serve it to the
audience after the concert and it's also
after hearing and seeing us and smelling
the vegetables which will be intense in
there because it's so small this theater
and then you can also eat it you never
get it out of your head anymore if
you're in the orchestra to look
vegetables in another way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a nice instrument has the purity and the
clarity of the heavenly realm it's not
of the earth in the way that a wooden
instrument would be there's so much
potential in ice as an acoustic material
[Music]
my name is Tim Lynn Hart and I am the
founder of ice music ice music is the
music that we make on this Orchestra of
ice instruments the idea first came to
me about 21 years ago I was an ice
sculptor for many years decided one of
my sculptures I'd like to build a giant
violin and I had a friend who was
building guitars and he just asked the
question
gee I wonder how that one's gonna sound
and that question has swallowed much of
the rest of my life the instruments are
made of white ice which is a mixture of
snow and water it's filled with as
snowflakes and air bubbles and they're
all kind of different things going on to
make a single instrument of violin or
viola here the ice part takes about five
or six days I can probably build the
whole Orchestra here in about seven or
eight weeks we have violins violas
cellos bass guitars mandolins banjos
drums and xylophone
[Music]
ice music is not just classical music or
experimental music it's a wide variety
of different things
this winter we'll put on about 45
concerts the concert hall has a specific
design it's one giant ice cave the igloo
right now is ten degrees Fahrenheit it's
definitely an issue in ice music that
people's fingers get cold people play
with a variety of different kinds of
gloves
some people play barehanded but for me
the temperature is you know the thing
that I really need to make ice music
work so many people just cannot wrap
their brain around a piece of ice making
a sound or a beautiful sound when they
come into the ice concert hall and
they're just very very pleasantly
surprised and that releases a real kind
of a high for people and then wow it's
it's amazing
[Music]
[Music]
it's the same technique leg trumpet but
you don't have any buttons to press you
only have to do it with your mouth and
with your air
[Music]
I'm Timlin I am 16 years old and I play
in the airport I started when I was six
years old my father's Chinese and my
mother is from B ellos but I am born in
Germany and the airport is not common
there sometimes people come to me and
ask me a lot of Christian for example
where are you from and why do you play
the eye porn
for some people it's really crazy for me
I play with heart I love this instrument
and that music the vellus drink pure
Festival Ananda is an international
meeting for album players the best
players in the world come here to
compete and last year I won the first
prize in juice category at the iPhone
Festival other things are here Forks
dancing some kind of wrestling but the
most important thing here is to play the
iPhone
most of the players are from Swiss but
there are people who come from Japanese
Germany like me or the USA during the
competition the jury is blind so they
sit in a tent and see nothing they only
hear when I play how do you describe I
feel lucky I feel like yeah to play in
the mountains it's a great experience
because nobody has such a view
[Music]
I always thought you know a snow shoe
would really make a great cello a wooden
chair back makes a cool guitar body but
turns out that one of my most playable
instruments is is a golf club I'm seeing
that transformative quality in my head
all the time
what can I say out I'm attracted to
trash there's no way check out the Jimi
Hendrix of shuffle is a guitar made up
of lots of will jump he even plays his
zipper from Brooklyn New York welcome
Ken vampire my name is Ken Butler I'm an
artist and musician and known for
building my own experimental instruments
since 1978 I think I've made around 400
instruments this whole thing started for
me when I was in my basement in Portland
Oregon and I saw a rusty old beat-up
hatchet put two strings and two tuning
pegs on it plugged it into my guitar amp
and was quite stunned that it actually
sounded like a horrible violin the ax
violin was the first time that somebody
said that's a cool idea
[Music]
if I go walking around the neighborhood
everywhere you look you see such amazing
conglomerations of potential sculpture
there's crutches tennis rackets parts of
furniture boom I'm right there with it
you know what I build stringed
instruments really just need three
things the head the neck and the body a
spoon has that parameter a key looks
like a guitar as you know and then this
little body this is from a very
inexpensive mandolin of course some of
the things become crazy Baroque
assemblages of multiple multiple necks
it's ridiculous but that's how it works
my shovel guitar I guess it's a small
snow shovel it's just a four key object
and it sounds unbelievably beautiful the
qualities and characters at the golf
club ass is amazing this one is made
from a beach paddle that has a the
ukulele neck and a cane
sometimes people think my intention is
humour it's not
I think it's surprising to people when I
can generate genuine emotion and meaning
and real music on something as
ridiculous as a hockey stick or tennis
racket or a broom or a shovel or a golf
club at the real core of what I'm doing
its to communicate to other people that
the things right around them can be
magical and transformative and even
spiritual who knows if if I hadn't found
that axe what would have happened
[Music]
I'm sure if someone were to look inside
my window while I'm playing they
probably would have no idea what's going
on in here to watch a theremin being
played looks really strange
[Music]
my name is Palelei and Stickney and one
of the instruments I'd love to play is
severe a man like what the hell is that
I don't know so the diamonds a
synthesizer and it's a synthesizer
that's not controlled with the use of a
keyboard like a piano I'm controlling
the pitches with my left hand and this
hand is just the articulation hands the
volume
[Music]
it's controlled without any physical
contact and you can make it like the
birds the really big challenge with the
instrument is its reacting not just to
my hands and how they're moving in my
fingers it's sensitive as well into my
whole body I've recorded on an album of
David Burns Grace Jones the Indigo Girls
it's such a new instrument still that
there's nobody who's going to stand
there and say you're not doing it the
way it's supposed to be done I don't
think there's anything else like it it
doesn't relate to anything else I've
ever played
you